السلام عليكم اولا كان في حد بيغلط في
هندسه وقال فيه كبير هندسه وهنغير كبير
هندسه وبتاع صح في ناس كتيره هنا صح انا
جاي مين اللي قال كده
مين انت قلت كده
فهنا انت بتكلم ناس مختلف الاعمار مختلف
الاماكن مختلف الفيدز فانا هطلع اقول لك
ايه فكان الموضوع بالنسبه لي قرار غريب
شويه اوافقش
ماشي خلاص وافقت بس حته كده ان انا قلت
ممكن اطلع اساعد في حاجتين وانا عايز اطلع
اتكلم في نقطتين كده اول نقطه عايز اطلع
اتكلم معكم عليها في يا شباب حاجه كده
غريبه اسمها روبوتيكس صح
لكن سمعنا حد بيشتغل في الروبوتيكس
ليه عشان خاطر ان في بابا اسمه التخصص
يقول لك انا لازم اكون متخصص في الارض وير
لازم اكون متخصص سوفت وير لازم اكون متخصص
في الاي تي لازم اكون متخصص في الباذنجان
صح لازم وفعلا دي حقيقه فعلا دي حقيقه ما
حدش يقدر ينكر كده طب ما في مجال اسمه
صح ايه يعني ايه يعني
بمنتهى البساطه خالص هو انك بتتحكم في
الهاردو يلا لمبات والكلام ده كله عن طريق
السوفت وير
طب يعني كده انت المفروض تكون فاهم
هاردوير وفاهم سوفت وير فين التخصص
صح هو التخصص حاجه حلوه مش بقول دكتور
مهندس لا ما بقولكش كده بقول لك ان انت
لازم تكون متفتح على مجالات معينه لازم
تكون مفتح على مجالات كثير هقول لك مثال
بسيط تخيل معايا كده ان انت دخلت على شخص
عندي 60 سنه قاعد في الصحراء من يوم ما
اتولد جمال وبيرعى وبس وجيت قلت له ايه
لا في حته حديده خلاص الو هكلم اللي في
الصحراء الشرقيه ويرد علي هيقوم باصص لك
كده ويبص للصنم اللي بيقبضه قاعد يبص
للاثنين يبص كده ويبص كده وفجاه يبص لك
امنت بالله امنت بالله خلاص انا بعبدك
دلوقتي انت بتقول لي ان في حاجه اسمها
حديده وبتكلم بها وبتنقل المكان للتاني هو
هيبقى مستغرب جدا ودي حاجه منطقيه طب انا
هسالك سؤال دلوقتي لو انا جيت دلوقتي وقفت
قدامك قلت لك انا اقدر اقعد على الهوا
هتستغرب
هتقول لي ايه يا صعبه صح
لان احنا شفنا دلوقتي حاجات كتيره بتدل
على المجال ده كله طيب قبل ما ابدا معك
بقى انا المفروض اشتغل في ايه انا اللي
انت عارفه عني ان انا مهندس ميكر مش مهم
خالص
على قد ما انا بس عايز اوصل لك نقطه معينه
وهي انك اشتغل في مجال حلو مجال واحد
اشتغل فيه ولكن انت وسع انا كنت في الاول
لما تخصصتم وكنت بشتغل في الكليه بشتغل
بكده قلت لا حول اي تي اللي هو اصلا له
علاقه عادي خالص مش مشكله خالص
من غير سيستم خلاص طيب حلو جدا بعد كده
اتعلمت ميكانيكال ديزاين فبقى عندي الفكره
الكونسبت بتاعي ان انا بشتغل
وكمان بعرف اصمم شويه فسمعت بقى على
المجال اسمه مجال ايه
طيب اشتغل روبوكس بقى دلوقتي اه ما تشتغل
طب هل هو موجود في مصر
لا لا مش موجود في مصر مش هقولها لك في
وشك بصراحه هو صعب ولكن هل دي حاجه بتخليك
تشتغلش لا مش حاجه عادي تقدر تشتغل والله
بمنتهى السهوله خالص هقول لك دليل بسيط
انا ما بحبش اتكلم اقول لك انا عملت حاجه
ولكن هتكلم معاك كده عن تجربه بسيطه وفعلا
موجوده في مصر موجوده في مصر
بص يا سيدي سريعا كده مش حابب اطول عليك
خفيفه ومش بحب اطول فيها انا كنت
لسه في اول سنه من حوالي خمس سنين تقريبا
كان في دوري بتاع الكليه كده بتاع كوره
وانا بحب العب كوره يلا نروح نلعب كوره يا
شباب حلو وصلنا للنهائي هنكسب النهائي
خلاص لا خسرنا عادي ما فيش مشكله بس قبل
ما نخسر كان الماتش تاجل مره انا هنخش في
التوصيل دلوقتي خلاص فالمات لما اتاجل
فانا فضلت قاعد في الملعب انا كده كده
محددتش المحاضرات هفضل قاعد بقى وخلاص
مفيش مشكله
فلقيت الناس في الملعب اللي جنبي بيقولوا
لي ايه احنا ناقصنا واحد تيجي تلعب معانا
والله لالعب معاك عادي انا لابس وجهز وما
عنديش مشكله في اي حاجه
فجبت اتعرف عليهم بيقول لي ايه السلام
عليكم معاك باشمهندس محمود الحداد ايوه
اهلا وسهلا حضرتك مين مدير فروع بي ام
دبليو في مصر
تعال اتفضل حضرتك في الاجازه هتنزل تدريب
عندنا
ماشي حلو وانا حمار ما بفهمش اي حاجه انا
كان نفسي اطلع ظابط اصلا مشكله كان نفسي
اطلع ظابط والله خلاص عادي ما فيش مشكله
لو دخلت هندسه بس كنت بحبها هندسه يعني
كام سنه كده
المهم جيت قال لي خلاص هتنزل التدريب نزلت
التدريب بس كان عندي مشكله انا هقول لك بس
على حاجه دي جايه قدام بس يعني مش بكلمك
عن حاجتي وعلى فكره مش بقول لك نفس تجربتي
مش بقول لك بس بقول لك على حاجه هتفيدك بس
في عايز اقوله لك الفكره كلها ان انا رحت
انا كنت في الفتره دي ماديا على قدي يعني
ماديا مقدرش اخد قرار ان انا اسافر واقعد
في القاهره اسبوعين المهم كلموني قالوا لي
هتنزل التدريب بتاعنا اسبوعين خلاص هنزل
وانا متحمس في التليفون ايوه بس هصرف منين
هقعد فين هاجر الاسبوعين دول فين اصلا
خلاص استقريت انا هروح وارجع كل يوم
بالقطر حلو على راي تدريب الصبح من الساعه
6:00 الصبح اكون في الشركه واخلص 6 بالليل
وارجع المنصوره انام وانزل ثاني
حلو خلاص لمده اسبوعين تعب شويه كان في
الفتره دي كان في عمليات بتحصل في سيناء
شوف ربنا جايبها منين في سيناء خلاص من
ثانويه عامه ما تنساش احمد حسن ابدا يعني
واحد صاحبي اسمه احمد حسن في جامعه سيناء
فنزلوا باجازه نص السنه في اخر سنه يعوضوا
لهم الترم اللي فصل ده في جامعه 6 اكتوبر
في القاهره فقاعدين في البيت الحمد لله
عادي سبحان الله جت والله اليومين بيومين
بالضبط خلاص وكانت دي العلامه الفاصله
بالنسبه لي انا من نوعيه الناس الرخمه
وبقول لك بالله عليك خليك رخم في
التدريبات اما تنزل تدريب في مكان في اي
مكان مش فاهم حاجه انا مش فاهمها على فكره
هو مستفيد منك هو هو لما بتنزل تدريب عند
حد لازم تكون عارف الحاجات دي كلها هو انت
بتستفيد منه وهو بيستفيد منك برده يعني هو
دلوقتي انت بتخلصه شغل هو المفروض يخلصه
فخليك رخم مش فاهم حاجه انا مش فاهم حاجه
قدامي في عربيات انا حمار مهم جيت قلت لهم
مش فاهم مش مش عايزني اشتغل يقول لي لا
هتتعبني ومش هتتعبني لكن مضيت اقرار على
نفسي لاي حاجه هتحصل انا المسؤول عنها
عادي انا لو ايدي اتقطعت انا مسؤول عن
ايدي اتقطعت عادي ما فيش مشكله وفضلت رخم
لحد ما التدريب خلص بعد كده قبل ما امشي
خلي بالك قبل ما تمشي احنا عايزينك
بشمهندس محمود عايزك انا قلت انا عملت
كارثه
حاجه من العربيه
خلاص هندفعها طيب هندفعها حلو
فجاء قال لي لا ده بشمهندس محمود عايز
يشوفك فمهم جاي واقف لقيت محمود مين ده
محمود الحداد اللي هو كان بيلعب معايا
ماتش الكوره في الاول خالص قال لي ايه
واشتغل معنا ويفطروا كده زيرو حضرتك انا
لسه في الكليه لسه داخل معملتش حاجه لسه
بقول واقعات مش مشكله
ما فيش مشكله والله ما افهمش حاجه كل ما
بعرف اغير فلاتر العربيه
انا كنت واقف اعمله والله العظيم خلاص
هتشتغل معنا هتشتغل معك بس انا حضرتك بقى
معلش انا ما بتكسفش اقول الكلمه دي انا
معيش فلوس اقعد في بيت هنا هتشيل فلوس
البيت مش عايز اخد منك فلوس حاجه ممكن ما
احضركش الكليه عادي بس انا
هم فعلا وفرولي سكن قلت بشتغل ما بين
الكليه وبين اروح وارجع وعادي دي كانت
البدايه مفيش مشكله خالص دي كانت بدايتي
مع الجزء بتاع الميكانيكا طب انا بقول لك
ليه الكلام ده كله اقسم بالله هنا في مصر
ومرسيدس هنا في مصر
الوحيد اللي هيشتغل في المكان ده بقول لك
يا باشا كنت بلاص في اولى اولى كليه حضرتك
يعني لا مؤاخذه يعني ما بتعملش حاجه خلاص
والله العظيم موجود عادي وهنا شغالين في
سيستم شغال هنا
على فكره المهندسين اللي شغالين في مصر
مشرفين عليه انا مش شغال بقول لك يعني
شغالين الحاجه موجوده فما تقلقش من حاجه
زي كده
طيب عموما انا مش طالع عشان اتكلم لك عن
نفسي خالص انا جاي اقول لك ان انت فرصه
بتجيلك من كده والله لحظه ولكن انا السبب
الاساسي اللي خليني اطلع اتكلم هنا في
تيكست النهارده انا في طريقي بديشن كده بس
انا مش هطلع يعني خلاص ومش عايزك تتعلم
ونصيحه انا لما كنت باجي هنا وانا طالب
كنت باجي عشان انا مكتئب من الكليه فانا
جاي اشوف ناس هتغير لي حاجه في بتاعي انا
مش عايز حد يديني معلومات تكري كده انا
زهقت من المعلوماتها انا جاي هنا عشان
خاطر اغير حاجه في المايند بتاعي انا عايز
اخرج من هنا انا عارف فعلا همشي ازاي
حلو انا جاي اقول لك النهارده كم نقطه كده
اولا يا ابني بلاش تستعجل في حاجه حلو ما
تستعجلش في اي حاجه انا عارف ان كلنا
بيستعجل على التخرج انا مخلص هندسه باربع
سنين مش حاجه حلوه وعلى فكره اول ما
اتخرجت اشتغلت الحمد لله
الحمد لله جدا كمان واشتغلت الحمد لله ما
عنديش مشكله خالص موضوع الشغل ولكن انا
ندمت انا خرجت بدري لاني كان ناقصني حاجات
سوفت سكيلز ما عملتهاش انا كنت بهتم
بمشاريع التي تكرك على فكره المشروع
تكنيكال بس واجي الناحيه بقى البيزنس
والكلام ده كله اجي اعيط جنبه ما عنديش
حاجه ما عرفتش على فكره
احنا اصحاب بقى 17 سنه سيب شكري هناك اهو
خلاص
المهم ندمت الكلام ده كله كان بخش تيمات
في الكليه تيمات تكنيكال بس ما تفهمش حاجه
تكنيك كان زعلت قوي ما دخلتش
ما دخلتش الاماكن دي كلها عشان خاطر كانت
هتضيف لي حاجات تبع اللوجستك وحاجات تبع
التعامل مع الناس والبي ار فما تستعجلش في
حاجه بالله عليك الحاجه الثانيه
عايز اقولها وبجد بجد يعني ما فيش حاجه
سهله يا ابني اللي بيطلع يقفلك على اي
مكان بيقول لك الدنيا سهله بيضحك عليك
بيضحك عليك مش حاجه اسمها سهله ما فيش
حاجه اسمها تقعد في مكانك والحاجه تجيلك
لحد عندك ده بيضحك على عقلك بيضحك عليك ما
فيش حاجه سهله في حاجه اسمها الدنيا بتسهل
بالرضا انت راضي عن ربنا اداهولك وراضي
على ربنا
سهله هتتعب وهتتمرمط هتنزل لحد ما توصل
للي انت عايز توصل له ما فيش حاجه بتجيلك
كده ممكن الحاجه تجيلك كده لو انت بتساعد
حد بصراحه يعني انا حاليا الحمد لله انا
ايو تي دي فولترا لو حد عارف خلاص خلاص
انا خلاص تمام خلاص
انا خلاص اسيب عشان انا كان في واحد كان
في جت الحمد لله فرص كويسه وكل حاجه من
ضمن الحاجات اللي كانت جات لي ان في واحد
جه الشغل جديد هو جاي يشتغل معايا وانا
عارف كويس ان هو لو خدك بتاعتي اللي معايا
هو هياخذ مكاني وانا همشي او هنزل درجه
اقل لان هو فعلا اشطر مني
خليك عارف كده مفيش مشكله خالص هو اشطر
منك ياخد مكانك والله والله كان ربنا
بيرسم لي حاجه في مكان ثاني والحمد لله
الحمد لله الحمد لله لو كنت فعلا فضل كنت
هزعل
جدا عادي ادي كل واحد حقه خلاص يا شباب بس
سريعا كده
ظروفك غير ظروفي غير ظروفي اللي قاعد هنا
غير ظروف اللاعب هنا ومش كل اللي بدا ينجح
ومش كل اللي اتاخر في حياته فشل كل واحد
وليه حياته كل واحد له كاريره خلاص يا
شباب وليس عليك الا الساعه يا من عند الله
ربنا يوفقكم يا شباب وشكرا لكم